hey guys we're here at Blizzcon 2017 I'm
Justin and this is Eric Tay hey guys
Blizzcon 2017 was really exciting there
were so many big announcements overwatch
had a new map and a new hero heroes oh
the storm had a new hero World of
Warcraft had a new expansion a new
cinematic and we were getting World of
Warcraft classic Starcraft 2 is going
free-to-play like there's a lot of crazy
stuff but that doesn't mean that
everything was covered there's always
something that it's missing there were a
couple easy ones that I think we could
point out here are some of the biggest
things that we wish had showed up at
Blizzcon this year I think one of the
biggest things missing and we kind of
knew this going in what's still kind of
sad for me to hear is there was no
Diablo news at all I was really hoping
again second year in a row Diablo 2
remastered maybe um I viewed it as like
a good way to kind of stall time for the
inevitable d4 right Diablo 4 has got to
be on its way at some point that was the
other thing I was hoping for maybe just
like d4 logo and that's it like we'll
call it a day I'm ok with that like that
could be as ambiguous as he wanted to be
but d4 logo would be nice the avila for
logo but yeah it sucks to see that no
diablo news this year another big one
now that we're talking about remasters
is the fact that we didn't see like a
Warcraft remastered I thought that would
be another easy thing for them to do
maybe they were testing the waters with
Starcraft and Master to see you know
what the interest was with realtime
strategy games I'm not sure but Warcraft
was another big remaster that a lot of
people I think want and we didn't see
again this year yeah it's it's a beloved
franchise and we haven't got a lot of
RTS news outside of Starcraft 2 going
free-to-play RTS has kind of been
missing from that Blizzard Pantheon and
so many people want to re-experience to
go back and play those classic Warcraft
games it felt like something that was
missing so we did get a bunch of
hearthstone news as well of course we're
gonna get a new expansion like these
things are just on a path we know when
we're gonna get these beats but we still
don't have a lot of heroes like I think
it's kind of crazy that when you go into
that hearthstone store there there's
really only three heroes to buy we've
had other heroes but they've only been
through promotional ways to get them
I kind of want to change that up but
like I'd love to have some more heroes
every month we get a new card back I get
to change it up cosmetically that way
but why don't I have more heroes in
hearthstone I kind of expected that
announcement so we got a really
heartbreaking cinematic we got the
reinhard story it was cool to see his
past
you know his mentor essentially and how
that I can wall to map kind of like all
came together and you know having seeing
his his mentor kind of like dying on the
throne essentially sorry spoilers I
think it'd be really cool to finally see
that kind of like overwatch movie or
maybe like overwatch TV show because I
feel like these cinematic sports are
awesome and amazing but there's more
lore to be discovered and I know they
talked about comics and things like that
but I'd rather just like visually see
like either a series or a movie yeah
Activision a couple years ago talked up
really big their acquisition of some TV
studio so we have that Skylanders TV
show there's a Call of Duty movie or
something in the works and we had a
Warcraft movie overwatch is overdue for
a full cinematic experience and I would
totally watch that it would be so good
so all of that feels a little bit like
maybe we're nitpicking but it was such
an exciting show and there's always
something that we wish we had gotten a
little bit more of but for even more
Blizzcon stuff that we did hear about
from those hearthstone expansions to the
overwatch new hero stay tuned to game
spot calm
[Music]
you